all right Susan's with us in Lexington
Kentucky hi Susan how are you hi I'm
good days thanks for taking my call
sure what's up so I'm 50 years old my
husband is 55 years old and we've been
following your steps for a while now we
have what's a wire I've been listening
to your show the last three to four
years yeah but you've been following the
steps along um probably the last two to
three years we've been doing the steps
cool so are you debt-free
we are debt-free yeah good for you for
the house good for you okay so we have
our three to six month savings zero debt
cars are paid for and we refinance the
house we have seven years left on paying
on the house we have like a two point
eight five interest rate on that oh good
for you so well thanks thanks to your
show it's it was through our church and
it just changed everything so we're so
grateful my son has graduated from
college and then our daughter her
tuition has already paid for she or she
graduates from high school in a couple
years we already have her tuition taken
care of for college our question is how
do we begin saving for retirement we
have fifteen thousand right now whoa
everything was good do you got there
wasn't it okay so you got some catching
up to do
a lot of catching up yeah with your
house on the seven year plan and you're
50 years old I would just say let's load
up everything we can load up as much as
possible and that means if you've got
401ks available to you you load them up
you got Roth's available to you load
them up all Roth is still a good idea at
age 50 and 55 yes yes okay
yeah and over fifty years old you can do
65 hundred each so that's thirteen
thousand for the two of you into a Roth
do either one of you have 401ks
available I have a 403 B but there's no
matching on it that's okay fill it up
what about him um he's self-employed
okay uh does he have employees yes how
many two
all they've been with him oh it's it's a
contracting business they they've been
with him for a year they come and go
every couple years there's turnover with
that business okay he needs to look into
a SEP a simplified employee pension plan
because he can put up to thirteen point
six percent of his net profits into that
and shelter that and so you guys if you
just load up all of your retirement
options get get with an endorsed local
provider if you don't have somebody to
help you put all that together they'll
help you pick your options on your 403 B
and get get your two Roth's going at
catch-up Roth's are called it sixty five
hundred a piece a year and you're going
to be okay if you can load all of that
up I didn't get your household income it
and asked for that but if you make an
average household income of upwards of
fifty thousand you're going to be fine
if you do all those things thanks for
the call
this is the Dave Ramsey chef
you